bienvenidos ahora resolveré un par de
problemas sobre el momento tenemos a
esta patinadora sobre hielo que está de
pie sobre una pista de hielo y ella está
sosteniendo una pelota vamos a dibujar
la pelota
esta pelota tiene una masa de 0.15
kilogramos y en la patinadora va a
arrojar esta pelota frente hacia ella al
frente de ella en línea recta
bueno ella aunque está volteando hacia
nosotros su cuerpo está hacia este
sentido entonces arroja esta pelota
hacia el frente en línea recta aunque es
bastante difícil de hacer
y lo lanza con una velocidad de 35
metros por segundo el problema dice que
la masa combinada de ambas de la
patinadora y de la pelota su masa
combinada es de 50 kilogramos
la pregunta es después de que ella lanzó
la pelota
ambas están estacionarias antes de
lanzar cuando ella lanza la pelota cuál
será la velocidad del retroceso de la
patinadora
la dirección va a ir en sentido
contrario cuál será la velocidad en la
que la patinadora se irá hacia atrás o
retrocederá o reculara es un término que
a lo mejor quizás no estamos
familiarizados con este término de
retroceso o regular casi siempre se
aplica cuando alguien aunque no apoyamos
acciones violentas cuando alguien
dispara un arma y ésta empuja el hombro
de esta persona que dispara hacia atrás
esto ocurre por la conservación del
momento así que cierta parte del momento
un país a la bala que es algo muy ligero
y que es lanzada hacia adelante y tiene
una velocidad muy grande
como el momento ese momento no se
conserva el hombro del que dispara
tendrá cierta velocidad hacia atrás
pero vamos a hacer otro problema al
respecto como les dije el momentum se
conserva
y aquí tenemos que calcular cuál es el
momento de inicio al inicio del problema
entonces a nuestro inicio del problema
antes de que la patinadora lance la bola
la pelota
en este momento en esta sección cuál es
el momentum
bueno
tenemos que el momentum es igual a la
masa por la velocidad la masa conjunta
es igual a 50 kilogramos
y la velocidad es cero porque están
detenidos no se están moviendo
entonces el momentum inicial p es igual
a cero
y bueno tenemos que después de esto se
lanza la pelota a 35 metros por segundo
entonces en esta parte ya donde se lanzó
vamos a ponerle en otro color para que
se distinga
en esta parte donde ya hubo un
lanzamiento
cuál será el momentum
bueno en este caso ahora lo que tenemos
que estar moviéndose es en la pelota
entonces tenemos que debido a la
conservación del momentum esto va a ser
igual a la masa de la pelota que es
punto 15 kilogramos
por la velocidad que tiene que es de 35
metros sobre segundo
más la masa de la patinadora qué es
51.15 es igual a 49
85 kilogramos por la velocidad como
velocidad p de patinadora que esto es lo
que queremos saber
entonces tenemos que todo esto tiene que
ser igual a 0 que es el momento inicial
y eso que se tiene que conservar
entonces bueno seguimos resolviendo
punto 15 por 35 como ya hice mis
cálculos aparte
va a ser igual a
5.25
49.80 y 5 por la velocidad de la pátina
vamos a despejar esta variable esto es
igual a cero
por lo que esta sección la podemos pasar
restando nos quedan menos
5.25 igual a 49 punto 85
por la velocidad de la patinadora y la
velocidad de la patinadora va a ser
igual a
pasamos dividimos todo entre 49 puntos
85 es igual a menos 5.25
entre
49 punto 85 y como yo hice mis cálculos
antes pero si quieren ustedes detengan
el vídeo y hagan los cálculos para
verificar que este es el resultado
el resultado de esta división es menos
0.1 105 metros por segundo esta es la
velocidad de retroceso poder en la
velocidad en la que recula
tenemos que esta velocidad es igual a
cero punto 105 metros sobre segundo y
este tiene el signo negativo porque va
en sentido contrario de este que es la
velocidad o la dirección hacia donde
lanzamos la pelota entonces cuando yo
lanza la pelota a 35 metros por segundo
que es bastante rápido ella resultará o
regularán aproximadamente unos 10
centímetros por segundo
lo que es bastante si piensan esto es
una forma de propulsión de hecho así es
cómo funcionan los cohetes los cohetes
expulsan algo que quizá tiene mucha
menos masa pero es tremendamente rápido
y debido a la conservación del momento
hace que el cohete se mueva en la
dirección opuesta
en vemos si podemos hacer otro problema
un poquito más difícil en el siguiente
vídeo nos vemos